let's go to our caller from the uh
913 area code who's calling today from
913.
hi david can you hear me yes i can who's
this
cool this is andrew from the boston area
my question for you
is what can be done to sever the ties
between property taxes
and school funding um that's my my main
question for you
yeah this is a great question because
you have this perpetuating
cycle in a lot of areas where
the richer areas with higher property
values
are often collecting more property taxes
and those taxes are used to fund schools
which make those schools
better which makes more people want to
move into those areas which often drives
up property values even more
making the properties less accessible
and you get situations that essentially
i mean the interview earlier this week
with daniel markovitz about
uh the idea of a meritocracy not not
being what we had not also
not being ideal in its extreme form but
also not being what we have is
related exactly to this issue so i've
seen different proposals i mean
in to put it very simply you can find
other funding you could you could just
say property taxes
are no longer going to be directly
funding the school
so for example property taxes may be
pooled or partially pooled at the state
level
and then redistributed out now it not a
hundred percent so if you have a place
with really high property taxes
they would send a portion of the taxes
to the state
a place with lower property tax of
receipts would send
a portion to the state and then the
state would sort of redistribute
more evenly to try to improve the
schools that that are not quite so good
but of course the people
that are paying the higher property
taxes are going to resist that they're
going to say wait
i'm paying more so that my kids can go
to good schools
and by living here i'm actually helping
somebody somewhere else and that people
are going to be furious about that so
if the question is how could it be done
mathematically you'd redistribute you
you have a common pool and redistribute
if the question is how do you do it
politically i have no idea
yeah and um are there any leaders right
now who are running
with this kind of uh at the top of their
platform that we can be promoting
um that's my second question and it's
kind of hard not that i'm aware of i
mean
it's certainly possible i'm not aware of
anybody who's making that their issue
but that doesn't mean
it doesn't exist
all right great thanks david all right
great to hear from you
excellent question thank you for the
call uh let's go to our caller from the
985
area code who's calling today from 985
uh hi my name is christian madden i'm
calling from baton rouge louisiana
what's going on christian um
hey how you doing it's kind of hard to
hear you but my question was so
i listen to you and i also listen to ben
shapiro's show
okay and so it seems like you guys on
some of the same topics
like for instance like the trump
speeches y'all have the exact
opposite points of view on those
shocking so i guess my question is how
is
how are those opposite points of view
from the two sides like
reconcilable in the current like
uh climate we're in i don't think they
are i mean i think that it's sadly
intractable
um i don't i i don't watch ben shapiro
so i don't know what he said but earlier
this week i covered tucker carlson's
reaction to trump's mount rushmore
speech and tucker carlson i think called
it
maybe trump's best speech ever and what
was so interesting to me about it was
it was a speech of rhetoric it was not a
speech of policy so if the question if
what you want to see in a speech is
what accomplishments does trump claim
from his first term and what is he going
to do in his second term
you didn't get that in trump's speech
what you got from trump's speech was
um dog whistle red meat rhetoric about
were fighting marxists and all this
these crazy you know straw men that
don't exist
the reason tucker carlson liked it
was that it was the type of rhetoric
that carlson himself uses to bamboozle
his audience it's
essentially what trump is doing so we're
looking at these things with completely
different
standards so i don't know if the views
are reconcilable quite frankly
okay all right well thank you man i
appreciate your input all right no
problem i mean
it's a very pessimistic response but i
think it's it's the you know it's
the reality